i know but i was so angry first of all
let me let it's like okay and then with
the mole thing after that it's just like
exactly gotcha i knew it it's a double
gotcha so my point is is that double
guys
i'm trying to let it go
i'm trying to interview there is no
resentment but you're bringing it
so i'm just saying i love you no it's
good you're getting it out there yeah
but let's talk about it okay yeah yeah
so when you guys came on the podcast we
said you we scheduled it way ahead of
time yeah and i told you before hannah i
said this was a live podcast before we
went live i made it very clear you guys
this is a live show i did barely knew
anything about the brandon thing it
wasn't even a big topic on my you know
in my head to hit
but i knew it was a thing and so i i ask
people about everything that's
interesting going on in their life and
it was an interesting thing i thought
and i asked about it and you guys i felt
opened the floodgate on that i sat back
and let it happen
and i felt like you guys were giving it
to me and i was just taking what was out
there i did i don't feel like coaxed you
okay or kelila all right or manipulated
you guys at all i didn't if i go to and
frankly i resent the insinuation oh
really yes if i go to a dam right and i
put a little explosive on the dam right
i didn't
just listen what i'm saying
if i go to a dam i put a little
explosive on the dam right and the dam
breaks and all this water comes through
right i can't then just go
you know i didn't know
right yeah but i had all this water was
gonna come i didn't put it
on that yeah you did you put a little
you think in your mind right that you
bringing up the brenda shop is a little
thing guys
you could what i'm saying let me finish
what i'm saying right but what
and my throat's getting sore my throats
are polyps yeah right i'm going to throw
some brothers but what i'm saying right
is is that you knew right no
yes i knew what i'll tell you what i
knew what i knew what you know that
we're podcasters right it's not like
you're not if we're not people that
you're having on that you have no
knowledge of who they are what they do
yeah
that's not my problem mr [ __ ]
explosives on the dam
but i didn't i thought i liked that i
liked it i didn't feel cokes i think
you're thank you for saying that and you
said that and i appreciate it
i didn't feel that at all i take full
responsibility of the fact that i was i
able to explain myself in a way that was
like um true to what was happening in
our relationship that i bungled he
bungled that as well explaining like the
open relationships because we never even
wanted to even talk about it bring that
up people want to talk about it i didn't
even know about that but we had that
because you brought up the thing i
didn't bring
water of the dam
bro maybe your [ __ ] damn had cracks
in it and the water and and i didn't
even set the explosive that's fine no
but i didn't have cracks i i did have
cracks but you just said an explosive i
didn't even if it was a bb
right not a bb even if it was like a
little time
i was a little pop pop
thank you thank you oh no no i was there
to repair the dam and it was so
fundamentally [ __ ]
that it bro i was there trying to mend
it up and it just what came forth was a
catastrophic
uh uh uh uh meltdown i didn't think it
was catastrophic i thought it was good
and healthy i still think it was good
you regret that podcast
i don't think so i mean it led to us
breaking up but anyway my point is
because
i i think that it would have probably
taken a lot longer to deliberate whether
or not we were going to stay together
but i don't see it as i actually see it
as a blessing in disguise because it
forced us to confront what was like bits
and pieces of information that was out
there about us that i didn't like so it
was like you know what we need to talk
about whether or not we're going to stay
together so it kind of forced us to face
it okay but i i personally felt that it
was a healthy open interesting
conversation okay
but obviously
it's fine obviously you disagree no i
don't disagree a lot of people came out
in support of you which must have felt
nice
yeah but they're also
other people [ __ ] brendan schaub that
meat-headed [ __ ]
how about that
yeah but see that's you can do that yeah
and congratulations
i can't do that
yeah i don't know how you can live in
that i don't want you to yeah yeah
because you're above it you're better
than that bobby you are
yeah but i don't want to worry
but i resent this insinuation
that i'm a gotcha guy because i'm not a
gotcha guy
oh you're not
what are you then
i i do you're a regular guy
i just was doing an interview for a
regular interview
you're anderson cooper you think you're
anderson cooper
you think you're ari melber like just a
guy from msnbc no you're not right
you're a guy what didn't you have just
said
couldn't you have just said you know we
don't want to talk about this yeah i
just said what's up with brandon schwab
and you guys are like
because
you kept reiterating that it's live
wrong
right wrong
before you said you know this is live so
how and yeah i was telling you okay
anyway i don't want to go we're going in
circles yeah you know what i mean so
that's what you did but anyway um
yeah that's what you did let's just
think about delilah for defending me
yeah
you're more i love you though and um
and you know the text the other day when
you said why don't we hang out and have
dinner and stuff like that i really want
to do that oh let's do it i would love
to i wasn't sure i would love to do that
i would love to do it too yeah yeah take
him to eat the big bread that made your
dome
ketamine who cares about my academy no
i'm cute he's curious go ahead
who's scary as [ __ ] let's go to the
details yeah you walk in there and then
right second by second time goodbye guys
you go in there and then what what did
they say
welcome to
hell
welcome to hell
she looked like she had gone through a
real ordeal
like i went